i'd like to start today with a video not
unlike so many others that we've played
on this show
you know generally what to expect at
this point a person of unclear sex
rambling incoherently and parading out a
whole encyclopedia of new gender and
sexuality labels
that all seem to mean the same thing and
nothing at the same time
and if that's what you're expecting well
you're exactly right this is the kind of
thing i would normally say for the end
of the show but but there is a larger
point to be made here i think so first
i must subject you to the video uh and
here it is non-asexual aromantic
and allosexual aromantic are not always
interchangeable
non-asexual aromantic includes
identities such as my own
i'm not asexual but i'm not allowed
sexual either my experiences are going
to be
very different from an allosexual
aromantic person's
i think it's just important if you're an
ally who's talking about aromantic
issues
if you're talking about allosexual
aromantic issues
make sure to say allosexual aromantic
there is nothing wrong with that term
just saying
non-asexual aromantic also includes
other aromantic people who might
not experience sexual attraction but
still don't identify as asexual
just something to keep in mind indeed
indeed i will keep that in mind and
thank you for that reminder i'd actually
been thinking about these very issues
recently in fact i was sitting around
with some guys drinking beer and
debating the finer distinctions between
allosexual aromantic asexual and
non-asexual aromantic
we'd actually draw a four-ringed venn
diagram just to keep it straight but now
we know and uh and that is very good so
thank you for that now for anyone
confused allosexual
may sound like the name of a dinosaur
from the late jurassic period but
it's not you're thinking of allosaurus
an allosexual person
is not an extinct reptile nor is he
necessarily attracted
to them though he could be no an
allosexual according to webmd
means anyone who experiences sexual
attraction
yes any sort of attraction at all makes
you an allosexual
so even if you didn't want to be an
allosexual it didn't feel
the need for an additional label to add
onto your sexual orientation
you have it anyway there it is just take
it and be grateful you brat
as for the other labels just listed an
asexual person is somebody who allegedly
experiences no attraction to anyone
however an aromantic person is someone
again i'm using
webmd here a site that sometimes makes
me think i'm dying
and at other times like now makes me
wish i was
an aromantic person is someone who
experiences no romantic attraction to
others but may still be sexually
attracted
so someone who who isn't very romantic
but is still
sexual may be considered aromantic
every woman listening right now is
thinking oh you mean like literally all
men
yes perhaps but we should note that
aromantic people can not only still be
sexually attracted but also can
experience quote intense loving feelings
so a sexual person who experiences
intense loving feelings towards another
person
isn't that the same thing as being
romantic perhaps again
but who cares we're on a roll here let's
keep going and please do not confuse
aromantic people with
demi-romantic people those are those are
those who have romantic attraction
only after forming an emotional bond
with another person
and every man listening is now thinking
oh you mean like literally all women
there's also uh lithoromantic or ochoiro
romantic
these are people who experience romantic
attraction but don't want it to be
returned
so they want to be romantically
attracted to you but they don't want you
to feel anything to them
otherwise known as creepers and don't
forget gray romantics those are people
who experience romantic attraction
sometimes but not other times
otherwise known as everyone and then
there are choiro-romantic people who
can't tell the difference between
romantic and platonic
attraction once again that simply
describes
every male member of the human species
now um
i know what you're thinking what about
pan romantics
well you're either thinking that or
something more along the lines of please
stop talking about this
assuming it was the former i can tell
you that healthline just published an
article about pan-romanticism
which says quote pan-romantic and
asexual are not synonymous
they're two different identifiers with
two different definitions someone on the
asexuality spectrum
could use both identifiers in order to
best name their lived experience
with romantic pan-romantic and sexual
asexual attraction
but identifying as one doesn't imply
identifying as the other
while your sexual orientation names who
you want to have sex with if anyone
your romantic orientation names who you
want to spend time with
well romantically if anyone romantic
orientation names who you
feel a pull toward who you desire to
cuddle or make dinner with
and who you want to spend all your time
with explains gray sexual
panromantic l rose founder of asexuality
spectrum resource secret lady spider
and co-host of the invisible spectrum
podcast
i don't even know what any of the words
i'm using mean
panromantic i feel like i'm having a
stroke as i read this
pan-romantic is one of the many romantic
orientations other romantic orientations
include homoromantic
heteroromantic and biromantic
someone who's pan-romantic can
experience romantic attraction to
someone regardless of their gender she
explains
okay so that's that's the
that's the breaking news here we've got
sexual orientation but also romantic
orientation
that's the latest thing hot off the
presses okay just dropped
romantic orientation you may notice that
the explanations offered by these people
always seem to do the opposite of what
an explanation typically is meant to
achieve
they explain things in order to make
those things more confusing and obscure
rather than less that's nothing new
we know that there are dozens and dozens
of sexual orientations which combine
with dozens and dozens of genders to
create
thousands of different variations though
the variations seem to be incredibly
redundant describing the same basic
thing
in different ways with differences that
are more meaningless
than subtle we've talked many times
about where this
proliferation of identity labels comes
from
and why so many people become so
obsessed with endlessly labeling
themselves
but now i'd like to travel deeper i
don't know if i'd want to travel deeper
but i'm going to
into the mindset of these people
all the way into the dark cavernous maze
of their convoluted egos
and see if we can't come up with a more
complete answer
what really is going on here
because it is something significant and
consequential
why are so many people especially young
people and not a small number of them
wasting their lives by trying to
categorize themselves
i thought i was boring because i'll sit
around on a saturday on a saturday
organizing my fishing tackle that's a
fun saturday to me
but these people or even my sock drawer
as much of a stereotype as that is i
will i will do that
and i kind of enjoy it but these people
spend hours every day
sifting through their own psyches and
dividing themselves into smaller parts
and putting each part into its own
drawer with its own label
what kind of a bizarre hobby is this and
again why
well i think a few factors are
converging to create this perfect storm
of total nonsense
many people today of all ages but
especially those who grew up in the
internet era
have spent their entire lives including
all their formative years
staring blankly into screens now this
not only exposes them to all of these
new contrived identities but more
importantly
often prevents them from developing any
functional skills or hobbies
outside of cyberspace these are people
who don't know how to do anything
and don't desire to do anything unless
it can be done by moving their
thumbs across a screen or a video game
controller
there are obviously exceptions to this
general rule but the fact is that
teenagers today spend almost
all of their leisure time on screens
and we all know that intellectually but
i think we often don't sit and really
reflect on the implications of it a
report from a couple of years ago
said that the average teen is using a
screen seven hours a day
not including school work and i think
that estimate is probably low
but assuming it's not seven hours and
then school work
that's just every hour of the day that's
the entire there is there's no time for
anything else
there's no time to do anything else or
find any physical or creative outlets
which means there's also no time to
develop anything like an authentic and
unique personality
a person begins compulsively
self-labeling not in order to understand
their own personality
but as a replacement for it
that's why the newer sexual categories
all seem to be centered around androgyny
they're not discovering their identity
but right rejecting identity
it's an anti-identity opting for
something
dull and indistinct where they're all
allegedly being their authentic selves
but end up looking exactly like one
another and together they look
like nothing a dreary blend of two sexes
where all that is beautiful about both
has been lost and only the most
superficial aspects remain
it's tempting to say that we're turning
people into sexless robots
that's not quite the case see a robot
has no sense of itself no self-awareness
um and that's the case everywhere but in
you know sci-fi
in reality robot has no self-awareness
but the other hallmark of the modern
western person
is that he is fanatically self-aware he
is consumed by his awareness of himself
he is aware of almost nothing but
himself in fact
he has the exact opposite problem of the
robot
while the robot cannot think of cannot
cannot think of itself
he can't think of anything else he is
obsessed with figuring out
what he feels and how he feels about
what he feels
and how his feelings about what he feels
make him feel and on and on and on
an endless spiral a black hole
now i'm skipping some steps here
admittedly the internet the lack of
identity
the narcissism the self-obsession these
only lay the groundwork
we still need the cultural influences to
come in and introduce these concepts
giving the empty people a framework that
appeals to them in their emptiness
but they're only spreading fertilizer on
ground that is somehow both sterile and
yet fertile
so so what happens in the end when a
person has no personality
and yet can do nothing but stare back
into the void of himself
trying to discover an authenticity that
he's long since destroyed
well this is what happens modern culture
is what happens
gender theory and pride flags with a
thousand contrasting colors
are what happens a person with no life
and who has had no experiences telling
us to respect his lived experiences
that's what happens along with suicide
and drug abuse and society beset by
meaninglessness and despair ultimately
civilizational collapse is what happens
[Music]
the good news is that we get some funny
tick tock videos out of it
so try to look on the bright side well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content